something that's beautiful about this
Film Festival is we do get to shine a
light on different places around the
world and educate everyone about what's
going on and what some of the troubles
and trials and tribulations are of other
people friend a better understanding
absolutely and I think DIF does such a
great job at that yesterday I was at the
soiree or share her journey which is
again something so amazing that they've
started I mean female filmmakers or
female talent in entertainment I mean if
you think about it we're in 2017 and
we've only had one female director who's
ever won the Academy Award no women have
it we have a lot of time to make up for
have so much more executives and yours
and more cameramen and behind the scenes
says and there are so many technicians
but it's always like an excuse man oh
but she's a woman which is so great for
being a girl I mean in 2017 we still say
that it does get said yes definitely but
if things are changing and it's through
people like yourself that are making
these changes how proud are you of your
daughter for kind of being a trailblazer
and really you know paving the way for
women of color but all women really in
general to have a bigger voice she's not
so much of a champion champion as she
looks to be these are things that she
believes in not that because she's
trying to be a trailblazer or she's
trying to prove a point there are some
things that she's believed it right from
the beginning she would stand for what
she thinks is great did you always know
that there is obviously something very
special about your girl spiralize yes
that she had something very special in
her she was quite the tomboy a regular
normal teenager he won't breathe yes but
she had this spark in her she had she's
very intelligent yes and she when she
puts her heart to whatever she that
needs to do she would take it to
conclusion the way she wants it yeah a
my way or the highway
that been in Hollywood because I mean
Hollywood I mean it's a lot of it's run
by men and then it's very old-fashioned
perhaps how has that been for you it's
not been easy yeah one being a woman one
being a woman of color another one being
an immigrant on all levels it's been a
little bit hard but I've got a lot of
love and affection from Hollywood from
whether it's the media whether it's from
the entertainment industry from my
colleagues but at the same time there
are stereotypes that I did not know
existed in such a big way like like I
was once told I was too ethnic for a
part I didn't know everyone has an
ethnicity yeah even cook yeah but this
the excuse was that we it'll have to be
explained why an Indian girl why her
parents came into America and I'm like
so it's things like that that make it
really hard to the pots are not written
for someone who looks like me you've got
a sort of claw your way in and say I'm
not gonna settle for the stereotype that
you expect me to play like a poo from
this from surgeons I don't want to talk
like that all the time yeah I mean
modern America modern India or even just
people across the world in general
Americans I mean look at America North
America in itself is a melting pot of
people from all over the world and that
kind of representation needs to be the
new normal instead of a novelty no
absolutely so when you come to tiff
what's it feel like for you to premiere
this movie here well I'm just so happy
that we were given an opportunity I mean
this is a movie with which is led by and
it's pockys first film it's a language
that not too many people know or hear of
which is Nepalese and our protagonists
are two kids who are from a village in
Sikkim who never acted yeah and pockys
mom who is a you know she's from film
school and she graduated from film
school so she took it upon herself to
train these two kids so seeing them
actually come alive in this entire movie
for me was just like wow what an
achievement and they're so cute
relevance of this film coming to deaf is
also the situation
this film can be planted anywhere in the
world and it will still be relevant the
issues that she's picked up she's a very
bold director they were proud of her she
said it all but said it's so sadly it's
so not on the nose
yeah but it talks about everything I
mean if you think but if you think about
like everything that's happening with
daca for example how and what happens
with kids who are displaced what happens
to their futures this talks about all of
that but from their perspective